a Zelda game without bosses is like a
box of chocolates that's empty you never
know what you're gonna get because
there's nothing in there to continue my
series explaining every boss and every
Zelda game in this video we'll focus on
the bosses and mini bosses of the
darkest game in the Zelda franchise
Majora's Mask but I do have a pretty
hefty disclaimer to get through before
we begin see the nature of Majora's Mask
is questionable to say the least and by
that I mean the notion of whether or not
the entire land of termina and its
subsequent inhabitants is real is
perhaps one of the most debated things
in the entire Zelda fandom because of
this I'm gonna completely wimp out and
refrain from coming up with my own
theory about termina in this video for
several reasons one of which being that
would take way too long and instead I'm
going to default to the official
explanation located within the Hyrule
encyclopedia which is that termina in
and of itself was created complete with
its own moon when the Skull Kid donned
the Majora's Mask out of the skull kids
corrupted in Twisted memories of Hyrule
now I know the elite theorist and
loremasters out there listening to this
are automatically cringing and roll your
eyes and it may be debatable but just
hold your horses it'll all make sense
because I will explain what I believe
happened in addition to what the
encyclopedia tells us plus there are
several very good reasons to believe
that the books are Canon for more
information on that check out this
fantastic video on that exact topic by
my good buddy monster Maze and thinking
of termina this way does explain a lot
of the extremely odd happenings and
tools and people and bosses that pop up
in Majora's Mask from Ocarina of Time
but anyway that's enough of that the
last thing I'll say is spoiler alert
obviously the bosses in Majora's Mask
can be pretty much all grouped into one
of three umbrella categories bosses that
were corrupted by the power of the four
giant masks bosses that are the four
giant masks and of course the big bad
Majora itself so let's start with the
first category of bosses that have their
own reasons or were corrupted and work
our way up the ladder the first bosses
you encounter in the game besides the
Skull Kid slash Majora's Mask themselves
which isn't really a boss fight would be
the two mini bosses of the woodfall
temple the first of which is a dino foes
this is simply a monster that does
appear multiple times in the game and
across the franchise that's really more
of a powerful species of monster than a
notable boss so really the explanation
for it is the same as it would be for a
Liz alfos or an air all foes or even a
bakoblin it serves the forces of
darkness and somehow either found or
created its own weapon and armor and
wants nothing more than to make link go
to sleep in a permanent kind of way the
next Minnie Mouse of the woodfall temple
is yet another repeating enemy in the
game the gecko with two K's however
unlike the dinofos the gecko is actually
not normally a bloodthirsty monster it's
actually a corrupted frog which is
otherwise harmless and kinda cute when
under the effects of corruption the Frog
mutates into a more lizard-like form
that walks on two legs and you know
tries to kill link and both geckos in
the game this one and the one that
appears later on in the Great Bay Temple
show signs of intelligence in that the
first one runs away from link and
primarily attacks by riding on top of a
killer Turtle monster called a snapper
and the second one encases itself in Mad
jelly which acts like both a shield and
a method of attacking Link in either
case when defeated the Gekko don't die
but rather just devolve back to their
original little frog body so you don't
have to feel too bad about it as far as
what dark power is responsible for
corrupting them though why it would be
none other than Majora itself or more
specifically the corresponding giant
mask but more on that later the next
natural boss encountered would be the
wizrow which is again a repeating
miniboss that pops up in the snowhead
temple and then again in the castle of
ikana Stone Tower Temple and the secret
Shrine most fans probably know that whiz
robes are not new enemies to the
franchise far from it actually with
their first appearance stemming from the
first game and stretching to being
included in 12 of the games in total in
each appearance Wiz robes are always an
intelligent species of humanoid
creatures that are very proficient in
Magic but the Curious Thing about them
is that they tend to switch up their
appearance quite a bit from being more
human looking in the original games to
being birds or maybe even the Rito in
the Wind Waker to being whatever the
hell this is in breath of the wild kinda
looks like Groove from Despicable Me
we're going to steal them all regardless
the wizrobes in Majora's Mask are
definitely more human looking and of
course are set out to make Link's life
as hard as they can they teleport around
their rooms and cast magical attacks
towards link and when defeated burst
into flames leaving no corpse behind as
far as where they come from though it's
about as unclear as any of the other Wiz
robes in the franchise they appear to be
of a race of humanoid creatures that
learned magic and decided to serve the
forces of darkness which in this case
would be Majora and its lackeys I don't
personally think they're completely
human though on account of their rather
large stature and goblin-like appearance
moving on the next bosses are the Gerudo
pirates from the pirate stronghold which
are really just Gerudo women and this is
one of those bosses in Majora's Mask
that's only really explainable by way of
Hyrule encyclopedia's interpretation of
termina which again is to say that
termina was created out of the skull
kid's Twisted memories of Hyrule clearly
the Skull Kid either had heard of the
Gerudo women of the desert or had seen
them before and I'm personally leaning
towards the ladder because iron Knuckles
and even the witch sisters koame and
kotake which are straight out of the
deserts of Ocarina of Time are also
present in Majora's Mask but they all
operate and act completely differently
with no ties to their original lore in
this game the Gerudo aren't desert
dwellers but are rather fearsome Pirates
and without getting into too much of the
narrative they cross paths with link
when link takes it upon himself to save
the eggs of Lulu who is the main singer
of the super sick Zora rock group called
The indiegogos the Gerudo Pirates under
the leadership of one particular pirate
named Avail stole Lulu's seven baby eggs
because the Skull Kid told them they
were the key to entering the Great Bay
Temple which they wanted to enter in
search of getting rich off of the
treasure within Pirates am I right
anyway that's where the Garuda swords
women as minibosses come in link fights
three of them in the game Each of which
are guarding one of Lulu's eggs next up
is one of two mini bosses in the Great
Bay Temple a giant eyeball monster known
as wart wart also appears in the secret
Shrine but there are reasons to believe
that all the bosses in the secret Shrine
are actually duplicate bosses from the
land of termina which would mean that in
reality there's only really one wart on
the old great Hyrule encyclopedia that
used to be an actual online resource
hosted on the official zelda.com but has
since been taken down for unknown
reasons wart was said to have been a
guardian of the Great Bay Temple at one
point it's unknown as to why wart is no
longer considered a guardian of the
Great Bay Temple but since it's a theme
with the game as well as most Zelda
games I'll chalk it up to the corruption
of the Great Bay Temple's corresponding
giant mask next up is the fun stuff the
bosses of ikana and by fun I mean scary
and depressing to start the entire land
of ikana is that of a forgotten and
Barren Wasteland that was once the
Mighty Kingdom of ikana and became the
location of countless Wars and battles
and bloodshed and just general
unpleasantness it's also currently
experiencing a very particular plague
one that entails the countless dead
soldiers and foreign assassins coming
back to life on the plus side this makes
explaining a large portion of its bosses
easier since said large portion of
bosses in icono Valley are the
aforementioned Undead according to the
undead king of ikana named egos dewikana
the undead are all awry and evil and
Restless because someone flung open the
doors of the Stone Tower Temple from
which a dark Wind Blows with all that
being said the first boss you face Icona
is the undead giant who served in
ikana's Army as its Captain known as
Captain Kita or skull Kida who upon
being resurrected immediately challenges
you to a race because he's got the Need
for Speed the captain was actually
defeated in battle which brought him
shame that carried with him into death
and is also the reason why he's dead
however upon being defeated by link he
passes his captain hat on to link and
asks you to give his final words that
the war is over to his men who still
Linger on as stall children in the
Mortal realm serving their Captain even
in death and after he tells link this he
asks his captain if he may take his
leave and finally he takes it following
the undead Trail all the way to the
crumbling castle of ikana link will then
meet the lackeys of the King two unnamed
stalfo Skelly Bros and the King himself
in the throne room upon defeating all of
them and curing their Undead bodies by
burning them with light egos do Icona
explains that the kingdom of ikana is
now fallen due to Petty battles over
ultimately meaningless conflicts the
kind of which was beginning to unfold as
his lackeys began to bicker just moments
before burning away into nothingness he
also explains that the dead began to
rise because of the dark spell
originating from the Stone Tower Temple
and after teaching link the elegy of
emptiness which summons forth a soldier
with no heart and is also the reason why
the Ben Drowned Creepypasta still haunts
fans to this day Burns away himself
asking link to shine the light of
Justice upon his kingdom with his dying
breath this light of Justice comment
also seems to imply that even before the
plague of the undead was a Scourge upon
Icona injustices had already fatally
infected her heart now there are a few
other mini bosses present in ikana but
they're legitimately hard to explain
because technically speaking they
shouldn't exist here such as the iron
Knuckles and the big Poe and the poe
sisters pose themselves exist as
lingering spirits of the dead and are a
staple of the Zelda franchise and in a
land soaked with blood and lined with
countless bodies lingering Spirit seems
to be a given but it's the iron Knuckles
and Poe's sisters specifically that must
have come from the skull kid's memories
especially the latter who are a group of
four sisters that once resided inside of
the Forest Temple of Ocarina of Time
which the skull kid lived right outside
of especially given that in the child
timeline which is when this game takes
place link would have never turned into
an adult and killed the poe sisters in
the adult timeline so logically they
should still be located within their
Forest Temple and the same goes for the
iron knuckles in the spirit Temple
however because we're working off of the
assumption that termina is a twisted
version of Hyrule that is somewhat
parallel to it we are going to go with
that explanation for the iron Knuckles
and Poe sisters and even sharp and flat
present in Icona Valley the final two
bosses of this first category are the
mini bosses of the Stone Tower Temple
itself the first of which is the gato
Master the strongest and master of the
Garo who are present all over the land
of ikana the Garo are also Undead just
like most of the other monsters in icana
and are actually spies that hail from a
country that was at war with ikana when
it was alive according to Pamela's
father who's a super smart scientist
Professor dude the Garo may even be
Hollow underneath their robes and one of
the reasons to believe this is that it
is Garo law to destroy their own bodies
upon death leaving no corpse behind
something they still do even in their
death the fact that the garam Master is
here within the temple and the fact that
the garam Master knows the secret of
flipping the temple is strange very
strange and actually leads me to believe
that the garam Master may have actually
originated from the temple see egos do
ikana says pretty clearly that it's an
impenetrable stronghold that hundreds of
his soldiers could not topple this
implies that it's not his stronghold not
a creation of the kingdom of ikana and
since it does require some jumping to
infiltrate which the Garo ninjas are all
too proficient at perhaps the Stone
Tower actually was the home of the Garo
but that's just a tiny little mini
Theory to explain the Garo Master the
next and final not main boss of the game
would be none other than the one the
only the creepy the vague Gomez now this
Scythe wielding boss hovers above the
ground covers itself in bats and has a
rather crazed expression on its face and
of course is one of the most unexplained
beings in the history of the Zelda
franchise so that's awesome the
aforementioned zelda.com encyclopedia
that's no longer visible online once
said that Gomez was a powerful vampire
which kind of sort of explains all the
bats although whether or not the old
official Zelda website definition is
Canon is debatable either way though I
think that Gomez is most likely a
creation of whoever cursed the land of
icana by throwing the doors to the Stone
Tower Temple open and here's why it's
because thematically everything about
Gomez is dark Gomez is surrounded by
bats which are nocturnal Predators Gomez
itself is so dark that you can barely
see any details of its body other than
its eyes and gaping smiling mouth it
also wields a giant reaper-like Scythe
which is to represent death and also
goes hand in hand with darkness and is
the antithesis of light and life and
since iconic kingdom is said to be
enshrouded in darkness that stems from
the Stone Tower Temple it could be that
Gomez himself is the Incarnation of said
darkness in other words Gomez is the
curse that was placed upon ikana the one
that's making the dead come to life but
who made the curse you ask we'll get to
that in a bit but a cool little ass
detail I'll cover about Gomez is that
his name in French is which means the
Grim Reaper and is also the French name
of the death sword from Twilight
Princess both of which are bosses that
wield giant bladed weapons and resemble
the Grim Reaper perhaps the commonality
is that they are both Bringers of death
or rather Bringers of undeath with all
of the mini bosses of the first category
of the game out of the way it's time to
start focusing on the main bosses of the
game specifically the four giant masks
that Majora created in order to capture
the four giants of termina which are the
four Guardian deities of the land of
termina which was once a land with only
one country and no divisions or borders
let's start off by briefly covering the
story of the Giants in case anybody
doesn't know or needs a refresher the
Giants were not only the Protectors of
termina but were also the personal
Friends of the skull kid perhaps even
his only friends eventually though the
Giants decided they wanted to sleep I
guess and in doing so walked a hundred
steps north south east and west thus
dividing the land into four quadrants
and leaving the skull kid behind this
broke the skull kid's heart and
reportedly he then started to unleash
his anger upon the people of termina and
this is apparently long before the
events of majority his mask eventually
the people called out to the Giants to
come to save them from this naughtiness
and they then told the skull kid to
leave termina where they will literally
tear him apart yeesh this broke the
skull kid's heart even more and then he
returned quote to the heavens where we
can only assume he then met the two
fairies in the Lost Woods and eventually
stumbled across the happy mask salesman
and then link and then the rest is
history now remember when I said at the
start of this video that we're going
with the encyclopedia's explanation of
the creation of termina well we still
are but I also wanted to state that this
history between the Giants and the Skull
Kid seemingly proves that terminum must
have existed before the Skull Kid dawned
Ventura's mask meaning termina couldn't
have been created by the mask right well
yes and no see I think termina already
existed and that it's a different world
that exists somewhere deep below the
land of Hyrule and its accessible via a
portal located inside an old tree in the
Lost Woods and no I'm not going to
expand on that because termina isn't the
point of this video I also believe that
the Skull Kid found this world one day
and began going their back and forth out
of curiosity eventually befriending the
the four giants before eventually being
banished from there however the Skull
Kid returns to termina after obtaining
the Majora's Mask only this time his
mind has begun to become quite altered
due to the corruption of Majora's power
either this or Majora really did create
termina when the Skull Kid donned The
Mask it's just that the skull could Don
The Mask some time ago which I suppose
is possible but unlikely since the happy
mask salesman appears here in the child
timeline either way at some point he
gets an idea and that idea is Revenge on
the Giants in the land of termina itself
now I'll get into the entirety of the
Revenge plan more in the final section
covering Majora but as far as the Giants
are concerned basically the four giant
masks were created by the Skull Kid
slash Majora in order to trap the Giants
inside of them transforming their
physical bodies into monsters of the
skull kid's Design One became Odawa the
giant masked jungle Warrior One became
got the giant mechanical goat monster
another became gayorg the giant fish
monster and the last became twin mold
the giant masked insects the monsters
were in my opinion none other than the
Giants themselves who took on these
forms upon their imprisonment kind of
like the imprisoned from Skyward Sword
which is demise's transformation into a
giant avocado with Squishy toes although
it's unknown as to what made them
transform into what they did
specifically since the four giant masks
eventually returned to Majora's side
though I can only assume that the masks
and subsequent monsters were designed
and created by Majora itself once
trapped within the masks the Giants then
became the scourges of the lands they
swore to protect each cursing their own
respective quadrants of termina the
Southern giant became Odawa of the
woodfall temple and cursed the swamp
into becoming toxic the northern giant
became god of the snowhead temple and
cursed the usually warm and balmy
Mountain into a fierce unending blizzard
the Western giant became gaorg of the
Great Bay Temple and plagued the waters
with uneasy murkiness and caused the
weather to become even hotter and the
Eastern giant became twin mold of the
Stone Tower Temple and covered the land
in darkness and undeath their Corruption
of the lands also led to the creation of
several monsters and bosses that we
already discussed such as the geckos or
egos do ikana but at the end of it all
after link freeze all the Giants from
their evil masked shackles were left
with one burning question why why did
Majora specifically curse these giants
into these specific monsters it's
finally time to talk about the ones that
started it all Majora and the skull kid
and here's another fair warning buckle
your seatbelts because this is about to
get crazy most fans know by heart the
story of the skull kid a mischievous
childlike Forest imp that donned an evil
mask and acted out and probably the
worst temper tantrum the world has ever
seen But the character that really gets
people going is that of Majora where did
it come from is it an it or was it a
person at one point and why is it now
sealed inside a mask let us begin with
what we know according to the happy mask
salesman the Majora's Mask was created
by an ancient tribe who used the mask
for hexing rituals which is another word
for cursing or bewitching so you know
this ancient tribe was definitely not
one of the good ones however that
ancient tribe that used the mask for
cursing others decided themselves that
the mask was too powerful and could lead
to Too Much catastrophe so this hexing
tribe The Mask away in the shadows
interestingly in the original Japanese
version of the game the happy mask
salesman says that the original tribe
was destroyed and that there was in fact
a Calamity brought about by mujuda's
mask and that quote our ancestors sealed
it away our ancestors as in his and
Link's shared ancestors which would be
the hylians themselves it doesn't
necessarily prove much but it is
interesting to think about an unknown
amount of time passes and eventually the
happy mask salesman gets his own hands
on the mask although we don't know how
or when or even why he knew about the
mask in the first place regardless the
Skull Kid eventually steals the mask
from him and cue the events of the game
the skull kid then begins to undergo an
evolution from harmless prankster to
more serious prankster to then taking
actual serious advances in his revenge
plot and decides to trap his old friends
inside the giant masks curse the land
with numerous ailments and finally bring
the moon crashing into the face of the
Earth in order to destroy the world in
defiance of the festival that celebrates
the Sun and the Moon things so far are
ultimately pretty easy to understand kid
puts on Mass gets corrupted by mask
until the dark encounter with the Skull
Kid Atop The Clock Tower see once the
skull kid's plot is stopped by way of
the Giants literally holding the moon in
place Majora's Mask detaches from the
skull kid and proves for the first time
that it is sentient and this is where
stuff gets super interesting it then
proceeds to call the Skull Kid a puppet
and enters the moon itself empowering it
even more and continuing its downward
descent to destroy the world but wait
you might be thinking I thought that was
the skull kid's Revenge plan why does
Majora who may have been created by
ancient hylians want to destroy termina
what does termina have to do with
Majora's Mask the only thing that ties
Majora's Mask to termina and the Giants
is the skull kid himself so here's my
theory and of course you're welcome to
believe whichever one you'd like now I
have two theories one of which is the
literal theory of what's Happening here
within the lore of the universe and the
other of which is the theory of the
symbolism behind all of this and how it
makes sense on a meta scale but let's
start with the lore Theory when link
enters the moon personally I feel like
he and enters the mind of Majora I mean
a limitless grassy field with a tree in
it being inside the Moon is probably
metaphysical you know probably there are
also children running around wearing the
four giant masks with one sitting alone
wearing Majora's Mask itself but the
reason why the mind of Majora is so
lonely feeling and the child wearing
Majora's Mask sits by themselves with
nobody to play with is because that is a
reflection of exactly what happened to
the skull kid it's what was inside the
skull kid's heart and memories and
because the Skull Kid felt it Majora now
feels it that's why the four giant mask
children are free to play amongst
themselves while the Skull Kid slash
Majora child sits alone it's a perfect
picture of terminus history told from
the perspective of the skull kid but
this fictional reality also shares the
memories of Majora that's why the kids
look like the happy mask salesman and
why they ask link if he'll be a happy
mask salesman too since Majora remembers
the happy mask salesman as the only
individual in the past countless amount
of years to pay attention to it
according to the old Miiverse website
that again has since been taken down the
happy mask salesman him self says that
he's never met these children before and
that he doesn't think they're normal
kids and that he's pretty sure there's
some figment created by the Majora's
Mask he even recognizes that they have
the same hairstyle as him so young yet
so stylish but now we're left wondering
everything in this grassy field all of
the dialogue from these children their
appearances The Masks it all stems from
either the memories of the skull kid or
the Majora's Mask itself but why well I
believe it's because of the fact that
Majora's Mask is now alive but let me
explain see the Majora's Mask when
Warren gives the use of the power to
make their wishes a reality much like
the Triforce actually but yet the
opposite of it see the Triforce will
grant the wish of its user but will
separate if its user is unbalanced
meaning the Triforce requires balance
Majora's Mask on the other hand creates
imbalance it corrupts it takes the
deepest darkest Parts within your mind
and brings them to the surface
eventually making those dark thoughts
worsen and completely take control think
about it like the Venom symbiote and
Spider-Man but if the Venom symbiote
also granted the wishes of Spider-Man
and now give that symbiote to an angry
emotionally distraught human being who
has not yet figured out how to control
their emotions like a child or a skull
kid that in and of itself is a scary
notion but I think that the true horror
is actually even worse see there's a
reason why Majora's Mask initially
wasn't alive but it is now and why it
was so terrifying to the ancient tribe
once they discovered its true nature in
my opinion Majora's Mask darkens the
wearer's heart because it feeds off of
it it grows from it and eventually it
becomes alive because of it and forms a
literal incarnation of the darkness of
its wearer's heart their darkest desires
their deepest hurts their inescapable
loneliness and the culmination of all of
their wrath and that is the
heartbreaking deep dark horror of
Majora's Mask it's why Majora pushed the
dark thoughts and feelings within the
skull kid to the surface it's why Majora
continued to enter the moon and pursue
the same dark intentions given to it
from the skull kid it's why the moon
Area created by Majora is lonely and
desolate and it's why Majora itself is
wild and childish and full of Wrath like
the skull kid and begins forming a veiny
organic body based off of these very
emotions in front of our eyes and we
know this is the entire darkness of
Majora because after defeating it the
evil has officially escaped The Mask
proven by the happy mask salesman but
one other aspect of the final fight that
I don't have to explain but I will
anyway because according to the Hyrule
Historia is the canonical version of
events would be the fierce deities mask
that link Dawns in order to transform
into the fierce deity and kill Majora's
Mask once and for all the Japanese term
for it is kishin which is used to refer
to gods that have a righteous Fury
against the enemies of humanity and
according to aonuma himself the fierce
deity mask is supposed to be the
culmination of all the memories of
terminus people their combined will if
you will it seems to me that just like
Majora's Mask is the Incarnation of
Darkness of the skull kid's heart the
fierce deity is the Incarnation of the
righteous Fury of humanity now it's
given to link from inside the Majora
moon Area from the child representing
Majora itself so that they can play good
cop bad cop before fighting which is
strange but makes more sense when you
look at the situation symbolically and
to explain the symbolism let's start
again with Majora's Mask The Deadly
heart-shaped ancient hexing mask is a
picture of what happens if the dark and
harmful will towards others inside our
hearts is left unchecked specifically
with a focus on how angry and wrathful
we can be in our childhood when our
emotions have yet to mature and the
masks that link gives to the Moon
children that run around wanting nothing
but to play games represents the
different pieces of our childhoods our
imaginations the games we would play and
when you give the final piece of your
immaturity away you receive the more
grim and serious maturity of adulthood
in return which has the power to destroy
even the darkest of childhood intentions
or hurts because after all isn't the
skull kid's wrath warranted wasn't he
hurt by the Giants his closest friends
the problem is he went too far and
wasn't mature enough to deal with it so
simply put Majora's Mask to me among
many things is an allegory for growing
up and overcoming and defeating the
traumas of our childhood the darkness we
so often bring with us but that's just
my thoughts on the matter speaking of my
thoughts though this turned out to be
the longest and most thought intensive
boss lore video yet or at least it felt
that way when I was researching it if
you enjoyed it or my efforts into making
it please consider leaving a like on the
video and subscribe if you haven't
already for much more to come seriously
you can always unsubscribe if you change
your mind so give it a shot if you
learned something new or if I missed
something let me know in the comments
below and also let me know which game
you'd like me to cover next honestly I'm
probably going to start up the series
for the Metroid franchise pretty soon so
you're going to want to stick around for
that huge thanks as always to my Bandit
crew of which I have a few new names to
announce say hello to Gemma F Zack p and
meme Supreme all of which who joined up
recently thank you guys so much you guys
are the reason why this channel is
possible and if you watching are
interested in joining up or helping keep
this channel afloat check out the links
in my description below that's about all
I've got for this one so be sure to
follow me on my socials and I'll see you
next time this is Bandit signing out
peace
[Music]
thank you